le second débat de ce sens public avec
mes invités mini zappalski bonsoir vous
êtes communicante politique Jean-Pierre
minière bonsoir avocat docteur en droit
Paris impôts Sorbonne Matthieu souquier
bonsoir essayé coteur avec Damien
floraux de la flambée populiste c'est
aux éditions plomb et Mathieu croissant
d'eau évidemment est resté à mes côtés
alors nouvelle distribution pour
employer un terme français et pas
nouveau casting dans ce studio donc
nouvelle réaction à la nomination
d'Elisabeth band ça m'intéresse tous les
trois de vous entendre c'est quand même
on l'a un peu évoqué avec Mathieu c'est
quasiment le premier nom qui est sorti
du chapeau dans dans les 24 ou 48 heures
qui ont qui ont suivi la victoire de la
victoire d'Emmanuel Macron comment vous
analyser c'est pas du tout pour être
méprisante vis-à-vis d'elle mais c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qu'on avait
entendu très rapidement
c'est pas nouveau enfin c'est pas
nouveau c'est vrai qu'on nous a vendu un
président nouveau un quinquennat nouveau
c'est quelqu'un qui était déjà là qui
est très habitué et moi je trouve ça
assez malin parce que la seule une femme
bon moi j'aimerais bien que ça soit
banalisé que ça soit ça sera super le
jour où on ne commentera plus le fait
que une femme prémunise la vraie
nouveauté ça serait quasiment qui nomme
à côté pour la planification énergétique
vous savez les deux postes de ministres
planification énergétique et
planification écologique territoriale de
mémoire ça serait marrant qu'il y a un
très haut féminin là ça serait vraiment
nouveau ça serait banalisé tellement les
nominations féminines qu'on en met
partout et que ça choque plus personne
mais mise à part ça je trouve ça assez
malin parce que c'est une femme qui est
déjà présente du coup dans le
gouvernement donc c'est une personnalité
politique qu'on a l'habitude de voir une
ministre un peu austère on peut le dire
mais qui a fait son job et donc elle va
pas je pense être critiquée pour ce
qu'elle représente de féminin ou quoi
c'est une personnalité qui est déjà
investie et autre chose c'est là
peut-être la nouveauté c'est qu'elle est
très dans la concertation c'est une
femme qui connaît les corps
intermédiaires elle a fait déjà
plusieurs réformes assurance chômage
SNCF elle avait commencé sur les
retraites elle connaît les dossiers elle
connaît les syndicats le patronat elle
sait discutée avec eux et c'est
probablement la seule bonne nouvelle
pour un une méthode refondée comme nous
avons dû Emmanuel Macron le jour de son
élection après le second tour maintenant
elle va être une bonne gestionnaire
technocratique qui va probablement obéir
aux réformes qui lui sont demandées
comme un bulldozer qui va dérouler les
différentes réformes de manière très
technique et probablement avec la
concertation après sur la concertation
juste pour la petite parenthèse
l'assurance chômage ils ont quand même
fait une entourloupe aux syndicat en
leur disant si vous n'arrivez pas à
négocier c'est l'État qui reprend la
main et l'État a repris la main on peut
imaginer que sur la réforme des
retraites il se passe la même chose
certains syndicats qui disaient que la
feuille de route qu'on leur avait donné
était impossible
en même temps que nous en direct l'image
de la cour de Matignon et donc on attend
la passation de pouvoir entre Jean
Castex et Elisabeth borne dans un
instant et on vous la fera vivre
évidemment en direct Jean-Pierre Mignard
il faut aussi peut-être se plonger un
peu dans les trois semaines qu'on
convient de vivre cette effectivement hé
disait on est revenu alors c'était des
rumeurs mais quand même on est revenu au
premier nom sorti du chapeau quel signe
vous y voyez est-ce que c'est un
président qui a décidé de prendre son
temps peut-être stratégiquement parce
que le temps entre la présidentielle et
l'église étaient plus long que
d'habitude et que donc il s'est dit il
va falloir que je fasse l'événement
peut-être à un mois du premier tour et
que donc c'était de la stratégie
politique ou alors est-ce que vous voyez
un président qui a hésité entre
peut-être plusieurs lignes politiques
plusieurs choix il a sans doute hésité
entre plusieurs lignes
pour faire se disant qu'à chaque fois il
y avait un risque et puis il a choisi le
moindre risque c'est-à-dire la ministre
qu'il connaissait le mieux humilie s'y
connaît bien vous l'avez dit justement
les questions sociales et qui connaît
bien les questions écologiques et
transition elle avait été aussi été
ministre a été directrice de cabinet de
Ségolène Royal donc elle connaît bien
ces questions donc elle remplit beaucoup
de qualité de sur quoi c'est quelqu'un
de loyal de fidèles je peux pas dire
obéissant mais en tout cas il n'a rien à
craindre de la part de d'Elizabeth borne
qui est préfet quel sens du service et
qui pour elle le service ça se discute
pas c'est une de ses qualités mais c'est
peut-être aussi
l'aspect
finalement attendu sans surprise d'un
quinquennat qui commence sous le saut de
ce qui était le précédent et en ce qui
concerne la concertation c'est vrai que
pour la sécurité la SNCF 7 est très dur
pour l'assurance chômage ça n'a pas
marrant ça n'a pas fonctionné et pour
les retraites on n'a pas bien su puisque
ça se passait mal et puis finalement le
covid est venu tout interrompre donc je
dirais
rien de nouveau ça aurait pu être bien
pire mais il y a rien de bien nouveau et
c'est une assurance touriste
Mathieu souker comment vous analysez
cette cette nomination peut-être un peu
de vous allez forcément venir sur le
fond mais peut-être un peu de forme
ce que je veux dire encore une fois je
suis très respectueux du travail
d'Élisabeth borde de son poste de son
parcours professionnel depuis
Polytechnique jusqu'à à Premier ministre
mais mais non mais parce que
vous avez raison on va pas faire de la
psychologie mais c'est pas très fun quoi
donc pour avoir entendu certains de ces
discours bon c'est pas voilà elle
emporte pas la foule quoi qu'est-ce que
je veux dire d'une certaine façon ça
fait partie des commentaires qu'on a un
peu fait ou un peu entendu en tout cas
au moment de la nomination de gens
Castex mais donc c'est la troisième
personne que qui Emmanuel Macron nomme à
Matignon et autant les deux premières
fois il avait réussi à créer un effet de
surprise c'est à dire personne n'avait
vu venir Édouard Philippe et personne
n'avait vu venir encore moins dirais-je
Jean Castex là pour le coup l'effet de
surprise n'existe pas pour une raison
simple comme vous le disiez tous en fait
ça fait trois semaines que son nom
circule et par ailleurs elle est en
fonction depuis je crois le début du
quinquennat d'ailleurs elle a fait la
totalité du premier quinquennat elle est
en fonction de comment était au
transport elle a changé de portefeuille
et donc tout le monde la connaît mais
manifestement si j'en crois les avis des
personnes plutôt bien informées Emmanuel
Macron avait tenté pour la troisième
fois encore de de d'avoir un effet de
surprise en la personne de Catherine
nouveau train alors le nom de Catherine
votre 1 circulé depuis quelques jours et
même quelques semaines aussi mais là
pour le coup personne ne l'avait vu
venir et manifestement c'était son
premier choix ou en tout cas celui de
ces derniers jours manifestement disait
que elle était déjà positionnée pour
Matignon voire même qu'elle composait
déjà son équipe et que en réalité si
Catherine Vautrin n'est pas ce soir à
installer à Matignon c'est parce que il
y a une forme de fronde au sein de la
macronie pendant tout le week-end pour
lui
évidemment c'est le gage à la gauche
donc Elisabeth borne ça serait le gage à
la gauche même si elle a pas été membre
du Parti socialiste je crois mais c'est
un peu enfin elle a porté elle a
approche elle a été très proche mais
c'est son gage gauche c'est son gage
gauche qui l'avait promis il avait dit
femme et plutôt social mais elle porte
quand même en tant que ministre du
Travail elle avait commencé la réforme
des retraites elle a rien contre du tout
cette réforme donc c'est un peu léger
moi je suis d'accord qu'il faut
s'attarder sur la personnalité de
Catherine Vautrin parce que avoir
imaginé mettre une première ministre qui
a se passer là sur le mariage pour tous
venant de la part d'Emmanuel Macron se
progressiste y compris sur le plan
sociétal c'était très étonnant qui se
Dispa même lui-même sans avoir la fronde
de de son équipe et de sa majorité qui
ce qui n'est pas à l'oreille de se dire
tiens peut-être c'est quand même un
petit peu bizarre de la nommer par
rapport à ce que je propose comme idée
sur la société Jean-Pierre Miller est-ce
que cette réforme des retraites on verra
bien comment aller menée sous quelle
forme etc ça a pu être quand même un
repoussoir pour certaines personnalités
de gauche qui ont été
[Musique]
c'est pas on plaisante pas les gens
venant de la gauche mais qui ne sont pas
ralliés veulent pas donc d'une certaine
manière reste en effet Elizabeth Borre
mais c'est pas du tout une injure pour
elle au contraire c'est vraiment
l'immense avantage qu'elle présente aux
yeux d'Emmanuel Macron demande même
d'ailleurs qui il aurait pu choisir
moi vous voyez tout ce que ça veut en
tout cas pas de la gauche d'aujourd'hui
qui se dessine
mais les images de l'arrivée d'Elizabeth
borne voilà dans la cour de Matignon
accueilli par Jean Casset évidemment se
faire un accueille chaleureux ou alors
entre
celle qui était encore
la ministre du Premier ministre d'une
certaine façon quand on parle de cette
de cette hiérarchie c'est c'est pas
neutre alors qu'est-ce qui se vous
connaissez bien les les arcanes du
pouvoir Jean-Pierre minière qu'est-ce
qui se passe là dans dans la demi-heure
qui suit discute il y a des passages de
dossiers il y a un peu amicalement quoi
je pense que c'est pas très sérieux
autrement contraire très sérieux
humainement mais je pense pas que ce
soit serré politique ils savent très
bien l'une ce qu'il attend et l'autre ce
qu'il a quitté est-ce qu'il a vécu donc
bonne chance tiens bon c'est humain
Mathieu il y a quelques dossiers à
transmettre quand même
les échanger auparavant parce que encore
une fois on est dans une équipe qui
était constituée où donc il l'a connu
comme ministre il a l'un et l'autre se
sont pratiqués ce sont côtoyés on n'est
pas du tout dans la situation où vous
avez un premier ministre inconnu de
l'autre qui arrive et où là il faut
évidemment parler par les choses plus
compliquées mais il y a peut-être des
dossiers qui ceux qui vont se
transmettre à ce moment-là mais c'est
vrai que c'est surtout généralement une
un passage de témoin plus qu'un passage
de pouvoir d'une certaine façon et on va
j'espère qu'on pourra il nous reste un
peu moins de d'une demi-heure avant la
fin de cette émission vous proposer les
discours en direct évidemment on sera là
et on ne les rattrapera pas juste sur
les hésitations qui a pu avoir de toute
façon en se donnant un temps aussi long
pour choisir son premier ministre il
était normal qu'Emmanuel Macron a
plusieurs options et moi c'est les refus
quand même si souvent on fait des refus
non ce que ça montre en fait d'une
certaine façon qu'on que la surprise en
soit pas une en fait la surprise c'est
que il y a pas de surprise comme le
résultat de la présidentielle et ce que
ça montre c'est la faiblesse enfin le
peu de profondeur de Bang j'allais dire
de la macronie vous allez au football en
plaçant ou pas là dans la macronie à
partir du moment où il fallait trouver
ce type de profil une femme qui est
voilà un parcours politique une bonne
connaissance de l'appareil de l'État une
bonne connaissance des dossiers avec un
signal envoyé à la gauche ou à la droite
si ça avait été Catherine Vautrin il y
en a pas 50 000 de la même façon
quand même le nombre de noms qui a
circulé était particulièrement élevé
cette fois-ci en général quand un
nouveau président est élu ou qu'un
nouveau gouvernement doit être nommé il
y a quelques noms qui circulent là ça
fait trois semaines que le nombre non le
nombre de noms qui s'empile et j'ai très
élevé de Christine Lagarde en passant
sur
autant proposer à toutes et tous c'est
pas parce que dénonc circulent que ça a
été proposé et que ils ont refusé ou
elles ont refusé en toute tas de cause
on ne peut pas enfin a priori on ne peut
pas nier que le pouvoir lui-même est du
contribuer en tout cas à la diffusion de
ce genre de fille de jeu il y a une part
de faire turbuler le système on est
autrefois quelqu'un d'autre pour voir un
peu comment tout le monde se positionne
comment tout le monde réagit et quand on
se donne l'intensité soit vous faites le
blast l'effet de surprise qui était le
cas d'une certaine façon d'Edouard
Philippe ou Jean Castex Mathieu Mathieu
la rappeler et quand vous laissez
décanter des choses mais c'est normal
que tout le monde s'agite et il y a même
certains me prennent même un malin
plaisir à faire fuiter des noms qui n'en
sont pas à ce qui permet de au sniper de
viser avant même que quelqu'un soit
nommé enfin je vais verser le jeu de de
même pardon juste en fait le casting
final ou manifestement la finale s'est
joué ces derniers jours entre donc
Elisabeth borne et Catherine Vautrin et
donc même si Elisabeth borne n'incarne
pas la à gauche de la gauche elle vient
quand même de la gauche elle connait
Matignon puisqu'elle a fréquenté
Matignon du temps où Lionel Jospin et
occupé la fonction et où il était
conseillère technique à son cabinet et
donc il y a bien une femme qui vient de
la gauche et une femme qui vient de la
droite ça dit quand même la plasticité
du macronisme qui peut jusqu'à la
dernière minute hésiter entre une femme
de droite qui a travaillé avec Jacques
Chirac et une femme de gauche qui a
travaillé avec Lionel Jospin son
adversaire au moment de la cohabitation
pour à la fin occuper le poste à
Matignon voilà la plasticité idéologique
est quand même très grande alors on
parlait de ces trois semaines de délai
là maintenant on peut espérer avoir
relativement vite la le nouveau
gouvernement
c'est pour ça que je dis on peut écrire
moi je suis devenu très très prudent
depuis depuis 3 semaines mais l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles on attend et je
pense que Steve Jourdain doit être dans
les coulisses il peut nous rejoindre
c'est le rôle de la Haute autorité pour
la transparence de la vie publique là
[Musique]
hatvp c'est quoi rappeler nous ça ça
sert à statuer vite et à statuer bien
enfin c'est un des objectifs de cette
institution c'est pas simple comme
double mission surtout en période de
remaniement et d'élections législatives
à venir la Haute autorité pour la
transparence c'est une autorité
indépendante du pouvoir politique elle
est chargée d'évaluer la situation
fiscale et pénale des futurs ministres
en gros il s'agit d'éviter une nouvelle
affaire Cahuzac d'éviter de se retrouver
avec un ministre coupable de fraude
fiscale cette institution justement été
créé en 2013 dans le prolongement de
cette affaire Cahuzac son rôle a été
élargi avec la loi pour la confiance
dans la vie politique de 2017 alors qui
est contrôlé et à quel moment alors
juste avant la nomination des ministres
précisément la Haute Autorité procède à
un contrôle qui est un peu informel elle
vérifie le PDG des différentes
personnalités qu'on dit ministrable
autant dire qu'en ce moment elle a
beaucoup de boulot et puis après la
nomination des ministres c'est là que
commence véritablement sa mission le
nouveau ministre doit déclarer son
patrimoine il est clair tout ce qu'il
possède un les biens immobiliers les
éventuels actions les comptes bancaires
le rôle de cette haute Haute Autorité
c'est de vérifier que tout a bien été
déclaré et surtout bien que le ministre
est en règle avec l'administration
fiscale bref qu'il a bien payé tous ses
impôts et puis autre contrôle effectué
par la Haute Autorité c'est le casier
judiciaire consulte notamment le
bulletin numéro 2 du casier c'est celui
qui contient toutes les condamnations
judiciaires et administratives et puis
alors contrôle ils sont effectués donc
vous l'avez dit avant pendant et même
après la vie du ministre enfin la vie
ministérielle on va dire ça comme ça
exactement un ministre toujours
théoriquement en poste qui rejoint un
groupe privé bien pas de problème pour
la Haute Autorité c'est ce qu'elle nous
dit dans une autre qui a été publié
aujourd'hui Jean-Baptiste Djebari
ministre des Transports dans la journée
le constructeur de voiture à hydrogène
opium a annoncé qu'il allait rejoindre
son conseil d'administration la
domination au conseil d'administration
de la startup doit être encore être
validé par l'assemblée générale de
l'entreprise mais en tout cas la Haute
Autorité elle valide ce transfert elle
avait l'idée aujourd'hui aucun élément
n'est de nature à faire douter de la
manière dont Monsieur Djebari a exercé
ses fonctions à l'égard de cette société
voilà ce que la Haute Autorité déclare
aujourd'hui dans un communiqué la Haute
Autorité valide ce transfère mais avec
quelques réserves Thomas elle demande
notamment à ce que Jean-Baptiste Djebari
safetienne pendant trois ans de toutes
démarches en direction d'anciens ou
d'actuel du gouvernement tout ça bien ça
permet de rappeler que le recrutement de
ministre dans des groupes privés et bien
est soumis à l'approbation de la Haute
Autorité merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain
c'est quand même intéressant ce c'est
une ce nouvel outil Jean-Pierre Mignard
ça explique aussi la les délais pris par
le Président de la République forcément
oui c'est une évidence c'est une
évidence parce que c'est un progrès on
peut le dire c'est un évident progrès
parce que on a connu effectivement trop
de scandales publics qui ruinaient
d'ailleurs la confiance qu'on peut avoir
dans les institutions et donc
aujourd'hui il y a cette elle fonctionne
elle fonctionne bien d'ailleurs
j'écoutais ce qui venait d'être dit qui
était d'ailleurs très bien résumé là où
tu autorité est allée jusqu'à dire oui
mais attention pendant 3 ans vous ne
voyez pas vos ex collègues ou vos
nouveaux collègues du gouvernement
c'est-à-dire c'est quand même une
autorisation limitée contrainte vous
voyez c'est quand même c'est quand même
très suivi parce que effectivement il y
avait un gros une grosse politique de
des pouvoirs publics en direction
effectivement des hydrogène
effectivement c'est une société qui se
situe là dans laquelle il rentre et
c'était sous sa responsabilité que donc
elle a dû être en effet très vigilant
voilà ça c'est un point important mais
je vais revenir sur Elisabeth ce dont
nous n'avons pas parlé les uns les
autres c'est que il y a une campagne
législative ordon on l'avait évoqué la
première partie c'est très intéressant
elle va devoir
mener quand alors d'abord elle parce
qu'elle est candidate dans le Calvados
et puis surtout mener la majorité
Président Madame Vautrin c'était un
choix pour mener la campagne initiative
ça veut dire que le choix était quand
même fait plutôt de de se renflouer au
maximum plutôt à droite et là c'était un
problème parce que ce à quoi on assiste
quand même en France aujourd'hui c'est
une renaissance de la gauche ça c'est
totalement nouveau à tel point
d'ailleurs qu'on ne sait plus très bien
comment en parler parce que c'est en
effet neuf donc la gauche existe elle
aura sans doute un groupe sans doute
puissant à l'Assemblée nationale ce qui
veut dire que les termes du débat
parlementaire vont être changés et qu'un
si finalement qu'une femme venant de la
gauche censée mieux connaître les
réflexes de la gauche soient là c'est
peut-être aussi pour éviter une trop
grande désapprobation une trop grande et
je pense que c'est la première fois où
Emmanuel Macron prend acte de ce que la
gauche réexiste en France est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette analysé
moi j'ai l'impression que c'est un petit
peu plus cynique que cette durée un
petit peu qui est demandée par ces
modalités de vérification parce que il
avait pas le choix il y a un petit peu
un jeu quand même contre la montre sur
ces législatives il nous a pas fait de
campagne pour le premier tour quasiment
pas il était plutôt en Ukraine que en
France il a fait une campagne juste
pendant l'entre-deux-tours simplement
qui était assez efficace d'ailleurs il a
distribué à tout va un petit peu boule à
facette s'il a donné un petit peu
d'écologie un petit peu de social il y a
distribuer à tout le monde il a remporté
la mise il s'est remis tout de suite sur
l'Ukraine mise en scène d'ailleurs de
manière complètement très bien faite sur
la réalisation est très ridicule je
trouve je sais pas si vous avez vu ces
épisodes télé où il se met en scène pour
cranter les rendez-vous avec Zelinski
partira Moscou vu le le drame qui se
passe en Ukraine je trouve ça un petit
peu au niveau communication moi j'ai mis
un peu des doutes sur ça j'ai
l'impression qu'il gagne du temps encore
là sur les législatives parce que en
face de lui en effet il a la gauche un
petit peu la revanche de la gauche la
qui revient qui a qui René comme vous
dites
tout à l'heure Jean-Luc Mélenchon donne
une conférence de presse des des cet
après-midi il a réussi à exister dans le
débat mais surtout il a repris il a
revolé le pouvoir d'achat que Marine Le
Pen avait préamté qu'est-ce qu'il peut
faire Macron alors oui il a une première
ministre qui vient de la gauche mais qui
est pas très c'est pas elle qui va faire
de long mais c'est pas elle qui va
embarquer pour les législatifs parce que
c'est Macron qui est décideur et qui va
continuer à mener la danse mais surtout
qu'est-ce qui peut apporter comme mesure
il a déjà un petit paquet de mesures il
a commencé à donner une demi-douzaine de
de mesure mais qui sont pas tellement en
temps enfin audible parce qu'il a déjà
distribué à tout va on est habitué
finalement on s'est habitué ou quoi
qu'il en coûte donc le ressenti sur le
pouvoir d'achat côté Macron je suis pas
sûr qu'il peut faire un poids énorme par
rapport en effet un Mélenchon qui a déjà
twitté tout ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
tout ce qui promet lui sur le plan
social ça va être compliqué cette
bataille là et je pense que Macron a
retardé le moment de se mettre vraiment
dans la bataille des législatives moi je
pensais être compliqué aussi un peu pour
les insoumis quand même pour pour le
pardon la gauche parce que je les ai
tout à l'heure l'effet médiatique va
quand même s'intéresser à qui étaient
les nous on en parle et puis au nouveau
gouvernement
nous on en parle mais elle est
totalement reconnue les Français donc
nous on dit il y a pas d'effet de
surprise ça va être une très grande
surprise pour un très grand nombre de
Français qui vont découvrir l'existence
de Madame borne qui vont s'intéresser à
qui elle est d'où elle vient qui vont
découvrir la femme et quand on va voir
comment elle va jouer ses débuts comment
elle va s'exprimer mais j'ai pour
beaucoup de gens vont la découvrir
de notoriété je parle pas de popularité
de notoriété et je pense qu'elle n'est
elle n'est pas très connue du grand
public de demander dans la rue à
quelqu'un qui
ressortant allait sans doute une des
moins inconnue parce qu'elle a fait la
réforme du monde dans la rue mais je
suis même pas sûr que les gens enfin
peut-être faudrait vérifier
ce qui est quand même un avantage les
gens vont découvrir Christ une femme qui
a du caractère qui a qui qui est bonne
technique mais qui en plus a du
caractère c'est pas quelqu'un qui se
laisse faire l'autorité
on va s'intéresser à qui à qui cette
femme puis ensuite elle a composition du
gouvernement avec et on va commenter là
pour le coup les signes données qui
occupent tel poste donc quand même
l'attention médiatique et un peu des
Français va quand même davantage se
porter sur l'exécutif que sur la nuque
aussi nouvelle fois thème alors trois
réactions de d'anciens candidats à cette
élection présidentielle Valérie Pécresse
pour commencer qui félicite Elisabeth
borne et qui lui souhaite le meilleur
ensuite je vous propose d'orthographe la
réaction aurait peut-être aller un peu
vite pour pour écrire tout ça vous nous
excuserez Marine Le Pen qui voit dans
cette nomination le symbole de la
continuation d'une politique de mépris
de la part d'Emmanuel Macron et Fabien
Roussel le candidat du Parti communiste
qui compare Elizabeth borne à Margaret
Thatcher Mathieu Suquet est-ce que vous
la trouvez quand même un peu j'allais
dire un peu gonflé cette comparaison
alors ce qui est vrai pour une fois elle
vient de la gauche alors ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'elle vient de la gauche mais
que elle a en particulier mis en oeuvre
deux réformes comme le rappeler Émilie
tout à l'heure de réformes dans le
quinquennat qui sont quand même pour le
coup
qui font réagir la gauche de façon
relativement épidermique et on peut le
comprendre le scalp des régimes spéciaux
au moment de la Réforme ferroviaire
première chose qui est encore une fois a
mis la France dans la rue pendant quand
même un nombre de semaines importants et
puis la réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui a braqué en particulier le premier
syndicat de France ce qui n'est pas rien
quand on vient de la gauche quand même
ça n'est pas rien et mais de ce point de
vue là quand même je rebondis sur
l'équation politique et le lien avec la
législatives l'hypothèse Vautrin est
d'autant plus étonnante précisément que
c'est la gauche qui sort plutôt
renforcée d'élection présidentielle ou
en tout cas elle devait être totalement
à terre et c'est la droite qui est à
terre et ça on ne s'y attendait pas au
contraire Emmanuel Macron a joué la
campagne à droite avec le le l'appui
symbolique en coulisse de Nicolas
Sarkozy avec le renfort de d'Édouard
Philippe et de François Bayrou
normalement la campagne se gagne à
droite et puis Emmanuel Macron est sans
doute lui-même surpris c'est la gauche
qui s'en sort pas trop mal et donc de ce
point de vue là le choix du Premier
ministre ou de la première ministre
avait un impact au moins symbolique non
négligeable votre train s'était étrange
mais je dirais que du coup Elisabeth
borne à l'aune de ce qu'on vient de dire
c'est elle incarne quand même des
mesures des marqueurs de droite du
premier quinquennat c'est assez étonnant
et je ne sais pas dans quelle mesure
elle qui est qui dispose d'une
expérience politique relativement faible
elle a surtout fait de la politique
encore une fois en back office en
coulisse en cabinet dans l'ombre des
décideurs on verra dans quelle mesure
son impact politique peut servir
positivement la majorité présidentielle
au moment des législettes dans la
campagne de législatives en plus de
faire c'est une femme on est là tous
formidable il y a une femme Matignon
est-ce que les gens vont vouloir donner
sa chance à Isabelle Bormes aussi pour
le symbole parce que c'est dans le sens
de l'ifope de la semaine dernière 75%
des Français disaient préféré une femme
à Matignon j'entends bien et donc du
coup est-ce que est-ce qu'ils vont pas
se dire il y a toujours un fait quand
les législatives depuis la version du
calendrier et depuis la mise en place du
quinquennat il y a quand même on va
donner sa chance à c'est ce qui est
arrivé à Emmanuel Macron et avec la
campagne menée par Édouard Philippe en
2017 les gens ne connaissaient pas
vraiment tout le monde était pas fan
mais ils sont dit on va jouer en
cohérence entre la présidentielle et
législative là je pense qu'il peut aussi
avoir un effet nouveauté de du fait moi
chez soi
je suis Mathieu je suis beaucoup plus
réservé parce que
ils avaient de Burn est tellement
identifié au quinquennat passé et en
plus comme étant une personne ayant une
vraie autorité sur ces dossiers les
syndicats de la connaissent très bien
l'ensemble des mouvements écologistes la
connaissent très bien donc on peut dire
nous n'avons pas de surprise politique à
attendre de votre choix gouvernemental
alors oui c'est une femme et là on ne
dira jamais combien c'est utile vous
voyez où nous en étions pour
effectivement constamment le rappeler ça
c'est vrai et c'est bien
mais pour le reste on sait à quoi
s'attendre voilà ça veut dire que et
pour la campagne législative et bien les
gens on va se retrouver dans le même
étiage que l'on se trouvait avant il y a
rien de changer c'est toujours Emmanuel
Macron et c'est toujours son
gouvernement voilà mais on attend quand
même la composition de gouvernement
alors il va il va on nous dit toujours
il va être ça va être un gouvernement
resserré alors on commence à 16 et puis
au fur et à mesure on desserre les
l'écran de la ceinture et on finit j'ai
fait le compte quand même ils sont 40
dans le dernier du gouvernement cassais
il y a 16 ministres délégués 9
secrétaires d'État où il sera paritaire
ce gouvernement ça c'est j'imagine ça
c'est sûr mais une petite pique parce
que j'espère qu'ils feront attention
parce qu'il y a aussi toute cette
vérification parce que là on a eu quand
même on a des candidats quand même au
législatives qui sont condamnés mises en
examen j'espère qu'il va faire attention
aux côtés symbolique aussi de ces
nominations parce que moi j'avais été
très choqué que notamment il nomme un
ministre de l'Intérieur qui est présumé
innocent mais qui était accusé de
harcèlement ou quoi je trouve que c'est
un mauvais signal il y a toujours la
présomption d'innocence mais en termes
de symbole je pense que ça compte aussi
après sur le côté femme moi j'espère que
ça va pas te faire différence et c'est
là où on se dira on a vraiment obtenu
nous les femmes l'égalité homme-femme et
qu'on se pose plus la question et qu'on
se dise pas oh c'est la grande nouveauté
donc on va être sympa avec elle je parce
que c'est une femme on va être gentille
on va la laisser non mais en tout cas
je pense que chez certains électeurs qui
vont encore une fois découvrir
mais quand on regarde le son majoritaire
dans l'opinion c'est politique même la
réforme de l'assurance chômage quand
vous interrogez les gens seront même
pour faire travailler les les gens ça
c'est mal de films
jusqu'au bout et en plus c'est une femme
les attentes parce que là on a beaucoup
parlé du volet soci il y a quand même la
partie écologique qui compte beaucoup on
a eu quand même un président qui nous a
dit qu'il allait faire de la France une
grande nation de l'écologie enfin j'ai
pu exactement son expression il a donné
aucun signaux pour l'instant c'est les
SMS c'est les Smalls modular reactorse
donc des réacteurs nucléaires qu'on
exporterait qu'on vendrait à l'étranger
un petit peu qu'on installeait un peu
plus d'éoliennes de construction de 6
nouveaux recettes ça c'est autre chose
que les SMS
encore la sortie du nucléaire enfin en
tout cas la dépendance au nucléaire
c'est c'est un gros projet écologique
quand même je veux pas être c'est rien
enfin c'est pas un gros gros projet
écologique ça va être intéressant de
voir qui nomme à ses postes là pour voir
si vraiment on va avoir un renouveau
mais moi je suis assez d'accord pour
l'instant on est dans la continuité on
est dans la continuité Macron bis on est
dans une continuité de politique
récurrent des retraites oui je suis
d'accord Émilie mais il peut y avoir une
pratique alors elle peut peut-être
initié c'est là la nouveauté mais on
verra une nouvelle pratique
parlementaire parce que dans le premier
quinquennat tout ce qui venait de
l'opposition que ce soit de droite que
ce soit de gauche n'importe quel âme on
n'entenait jamais compte quelquefois
même un bon amendement était recyclé
blanchi dans la majorité pour être pas
passé un peu comme souvent oui mais je
pense que là on est dans une situation
très particulière car une grande partie
de l'opposition de gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale est composé par donnez-moi des
lecteurs d'Emmanuel Macron et oui des
lecteurs de second tour c'est très
spécial la situation dans laquelle on va
se trouver et lui-même et même la
première alors est-ce qu'elle sera
capable est-ce qu'elle voudra capable
elle le peut mais est-ce qu'elle voudra
un instituer une nouvelle relation avec
les oppositions et l'opposition de
gauche voilà et puis je reviens parce
que j'étais j'avais amorcé une question
vous m'avait interrompu mais c'est pas
très grave je suis là pour ça Mathieu ce
qui est intéressant dans la composition
là de ce gouvernement qui restera
resserré en tout cas jusqu'au
législatives et puis regrossira après
c'est toujours comme ça que ça se passe
mais là aussi ça peut être une forme de
d'argument ou d'armes de campagne
électorale dans la perspective des
législatives c'était équilibre de ce
gouvernement les personnalités qui qui
seront nommées ceux qui seront chargés
de la planification écologique etc etc
oui alors à voir quand même dans quelle
mesure Emmanuel Macron grille toutes ses
cartouches tout de suite alors est-ce
que encore une fois la composition de
son gouvernement est une arme au service
du combat électoral dans le même y
a-t-il une forme d'athon de conduction
d'un certain nombre de poids lourds du
gouvernement qui ont fait savoir qu'il
voulait rester les Bruno Le Maire les
Gérald Darmanin les Dupont-Moretti si ne
serait-ce que voilà en fait remplir soit
avec leur portefeuille actuel soit avec
de nouveaux portefeuilles ça donnera
quand même une tonalité de Drian et la
guerre quand même c'est grâce à François
Hollande
et sympathique c'est un grand ami mais
des fois il aime bien lire
alors donc encore une fois l'effet de
continuité a fortiori avec une Elizabeth
borne sortant qui devient première
ministre les fêtes continuité quand même
peut l'emporter sur l'effet de souffle
et l'effet de nouveauté et donc avoir
encore l'impact que ça peut avoir en
matière de dynamique électorale sur le
résultat des législatives on a évoqué le
duo exécutif dans notre premier débat
mais Mathieu c'est c'est intéressant de
de voir aussi comment Emmanuel Macron
peut-il tenir cette promesse d'une
nouvelle méthode de de gouvernement et
de
moins de verticalité en tout cas c'est
ce qu'on a compris de ces discours pose
présidentielle c'est là où et toute la
responsabilité d'elisabelle borne il y a
deux par son parcours deux par les
entreprises qu'elle a fréquenté de
parler les fonctions ministérielles
qu'elle a occupée une pratique de la
négociation une connaissance on va dire
de la négociation des rapports sociaux
qui n'est pas la même que celle
d'Emmanuel Macron pour Emmanuel Macron
vous souvenez quand il arrivait en 2017
pour lui c'était des gens qui vivaient
une forme de rente syndicale et qui
était des facteurs de blocage de
l'évolution de la France et pas des
partenaires avec qui on pouvait discuter
un petit peu changer d'avion ensuite
mais ça n'est pas la conception des
choses d'Elisabeth burn ça c'est la
première chose ensuite on va voir
qu'elles vont être ces premiers
marqueurs il n'est pas interdit
d'imaginer que son premier discours sera
essentiellement écologique elle a été
ministre de la transition écologique
avec un bilan qui n'est pas le plus
important parce qu'elle l'a occupé
pendant un an et il y a pas eu
énormément de choses de fait d'accord
mais elle connaît les enjeux pour les
avoir aussi connus quand elle était
directrice du cabinet Ségolène Royal
Jean-Pierre leur rappelait tout à
l'heure quand Ségolène Royal occupait le
ministère d'écologie et comme ça je me
dis si il n'est pas impossible que son
premier discours soit essentiellement
écologique voir son discours de
politique générale voilà mais mais et
que du coup on est vraiment une une
coloration très très verte qui
convaincra ou pas le programme plaira ou
pas mais en tout cas il y a des accents
qui sont mis que n'avait pas mis
Emmanuel Macron que ce soit pendant le
précédent
quinquennatologie et Mélenchon qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la question c'est
même lui le géniteur de l'expression
planification écologique donc si c'est
en effet ce que l'immatué possible en
effet souhaitons-le l'écologie qui
chapote le reste en ayant effectivement
un effet transversal je veux pas dire
transcendantal sur toutes les politiques
dans ce cas là à l'Assemblée il va bien
falloir se parler il va pas y avoir des
oppositions et des clivages fous pour
savoir comment on va réduire la
température dans le monde et rendre
l'humanité vivable je suis désolé sur la
question écologique elle demandera un
autre comportement des forces politiques
on n'a pas on n'a pas le droit
d'Emmanuel
même Jean-Luc Mélenchon et même des de
la nuque cetera parce que on ne va pas
se battre sur cette question là comment
se battait sur les autres s'il y a de la
bonne volonté de la sincérité mais il y
a des conceptions différentes de
l'écologie
quand il faut tomber d'un degré il faut
tomber d'un degré il y a pas 50
conception un complément pour ce qui est
de la gouvernance à ce stade en tout cas
ce qu'on comprend c'est que même si
Emmanuel Macron a dit que il entendait
effectivement adopter une méthode
nouvelle on a vu que ça son discours
devant les candidats de de de ensemble
législatif législatives son discours et
même sa simple présence en fait disait
bien que il se positionnait quand même
comme le chef de la majorité et que vous
pouvez le faire avec une vacance d'une
certaine façon
j'encaisse etc mais enfin il était plus
très occupé donc de ce point de vue là
il y a un premier indice et quand même
deuxième chose sans faire injure à
Madame borne on voit bien que le choix
d'Elizabeth borne n'est pas précisément
le choix d'un poids lourd politique ou
de quelqu'un qui pourrait faire de
l'ombre à Emmanuel Macron et qui
précisément même ne doit sa place qu'à
la bonne volonté d'Emmanuel Macron donc
en termes de gouvernance d'équilibre des
pouvoirs au sein de l'exécutif et et de
dialogue avec les parlementaires on va
voir on a parlé de la transition
écologique c'est majeur on a parlé des
retraites mais il y a un thème dont on
n'a pas encore parlé qui est sur le en
haut de la pile je pense non c'est le
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat le
vous l'avez évoqué très rapidement mais
le premier thème sur lequel ce nouveau
gouvernement est donc Elisabeth borde
seront attendus c'est ça il y a déjà eu
annoncé par Gabriel Attal un certain
nombre de mesures qui devraient être
voté dans une loi de finance
rectificative donc après législatives
mais il va quand même falloir envoyer
des signaux pendant cette campagne je
pense que c'est là où ça va être
compliqué c'est l'idée de de marquer le
quinquennat par l'écologie ça serait pas
bête parce que ça va être compliqué de
parler de pouvoir d'achat malgré tout ce
qu'ils vont mettre sur la table
rendez-vous compte tout ce qu'ils ont
mis déjà sur la table avec le quoi qu'il
en coûte qu'il n'a jamais terminé qui
n'est pas fini et encore des décrets
pour étendre des aides et à chaque fois
qu'il y a un souci il y a il y a l'état
qui est là Macron a recréer
l'État-providence pendant cette crise
pendant la garde de l'Ukraine et encore
maintenant j'ai à l'historique dans les
champs pof il y a une aide je sais pas
ce qui va se passer à la pêche on va
avoir une aide et le ressenti l'argent
magique c'est une drogue dure donc les
histoires de déficit c'est complètement
passé outré il a beau être quand même de
droite on a l'impression que ça n'existe
plus ça l'histoire du déficit mais
malheureusement le ressenti des gens
c'est que les gens ils comptent à la fin
du mois ils voient ce qui leur manque et
même si globalement la réalité même si
globalement on leur donne plus le
ressenti n'est pas là et il y a des il y
a des classes sociales qui souffrent
beaucoup et puis c'est le quotidien
c'est à dire quand on fait son plein et
que on sent que ça monte à 50 60 euros
et j'ai l'impression que malgré tout ce
qui donnera ça ne suffira jamais donc
c'est pas un axe de communication qui
est porteur d'autant plus comme je le
disais tout à l'heure en face il y a des
gens qui sont qui sont prêts à batailler
et vous le disiez tout à l'heure à
l'Assemblée si jamais on a un président
de la commission des finances qui est de
gauche parce que s'ils étaient le
premier parti d'opposition ça va aussi
discuter très fort sur comment on
envisage les lois comment là-dessus au
niveau budgétaire on va on va être dans
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus de
la mêlée et moi je pense que c'est la
revanche de la gauche en ce moment et
cette cette diversité des gauches elle
risque de se réunir parce que justement
elle va s'opposer au projet de loi qui
vont arriver on en a pas parlé tout à
l'heure au niveau social il y a aussi le
RSA conditionné ça va pas faire plaisir
à tout le monde d'entendre ça avec la
réforme des retraites c'est quand même
des choses que qui vont se discuter dans
l'assemblée la présidentielle a été
marquée par un fait relativement inédit
un une thématique une problématique a
écraser absolument toutes les autres ça
ça ne se produit pas en général il y a
deux trois thèmes au moins qui domine
les autres là le pouvoir d'achat a fini
par écraser absolument toutes les autres
problématiques alors ça a duré le temps
de la campagne présidentielle et ça a
permis d'ailleurs à tous les candidats
de ce polariser autour de cette question
ça a duré pendant toute la campagne
présidentielle mais ça fait fit quand
même de l'avenir et qui est plus
incertain que jamais c'est-à-dire que on
sait qu'on vit dans un monde
d'incertitude mais la situation
géopolitique elle est conséquences
macroéconomiques mondiale de la
situation géopolitique on sait pas du
tout les mesures on comprend que après
cette racontée pendant des mois et des
mois en sortie de crise sanitaire que
nous allions vivre de nouvelles trentes
glorieuses potentiellement avec une
croissance qu'on annonce qu'on annoncé
très forte très dynamique et un plein
emploi qu'on disait à portée de main on
verra quelle est l'histoire dans 6 mois
encore une fois le pays B en Europe de
l'Est il est il est annoncé comme devant
chuté de 30% pour les moins avenir 30%
de baisse imagine-t-on l'impact que ça
va avoir sur nos propres économies sur
nos propres économies et donc
précisément cette affaire là elle elle
introduit une vraie incertitude et une
vraie incertitude y compris par rapport
aux problématiques qui vont dominer dans
les mois à venir le chômage a été
totalement absent de la campagne
présidentielle ça n'est pas pour ça
qu'il va être absent des préoccupations
des Français en d'ici la fin de l'année
2022 merci encore je ferai très prudent
dans les attaques qui sont menées contre
la nu parce que des questions d'union
nationale sur certains points on se
poseront inévitable il faut avoir le
courage de le dire ce sera à suivre
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir à ce
débat Mathieu je vous rappelle je
rappelle le titre de votre livre la
France est populiste c'est chez plomb et
je vous donne une dernière image et ben
voilà c'est l'image en direct de
duo et on va pas les entendre tout de
suite mais on aura vu Élisabeth borne et
Jean Castex là passation de pouvoir
merci à tous